je le disais ils sont là avec nous
chantal hébert avec à son guichet surgit
messieurs dames
bonsoir à vous ce moment évidemment un
seul sujet ce soir ça a été le sujet
comme monopoliser toute la classe
politique et pas que celles en campagne
on entendu monsieur couillard plutôt
également je vous fait écouter un petit
extrême vient de donner le ministre à
chris alexander responsable de cette
question vient de donner petite entrevue
à nos collègues de nos joueurs extraits
en revue afin d'entamer un réfugié
politique
je vous explique en 12 secondes donc la
famille cordy on l'a entendu vous l'avez
vu la tente et pleurer aujourd'hui à
donner une lettre au mois de mars
dernier à son député député dans les
néo-démocrates qui lui la remise en main
propre aux mines et sidi oui j'ai reçu
la lettre et je les remises à des
fonctionnaires comme d'habitude le
problème mais je vais vous entendre là
dessus c'est que on avait annoncé
quelques mots qu'on allait accélérer la
machine pour faire entrer les syriens
chatel au ministère est normalement
semaine pas de cahier de demandes de
réfugiés
mais un ministre doit être posé des
questions comme de dire
et un co type quelqu'un qui a de la
famille au canada qui est prêt à parer
né de la famille pour donner au canada
si ça marche pas c'est quoi les raisons
et si les raisons c'est parce que la
turquie fournit pas de gens de
renseignements qu'on exige point final
c'est impossible à obtenir
dans ce cas la ministre elle doit dire
l'instant il va falloir qu'on trouve une
autre façon de fonctionner parce que si
des gens qui sont rocade qui sont prêts
à aider leurs familles à venir ici
réussissent pas à passer à travers notre
processus qui va réussir
et encore une fois décalage entre le
discours politique où on dit on va en
ajouter dix mille panneaux 10000 et cgc
auger entre la réalité pile discours et
les promesses d'il ya quelques mois mais
bien des cas il ya des choses qui leur
choix on accepte de les séparer né au
canada des gens qui sont dans des
endroits où la chair peut lé haut
commissariat des réfugiés de l'onu peut
leur donner des papiers ça ça veut dire
defacto là le liban la jordanie
et si vous êtes ailleurs tant pis pour
vous autres on ne peut pas dire qu'on a
ouvert le robinet alors on sait le
contraire en fonction de la façon la
plus bureaucratique possible moi je vais
à mon émission joues rosissent lydie
quelqu'un qui essaie de faire venir sa
soeur et qui dit en plein milieu des
procédures on m'a dit oui vous avez déjà
fait d'avoir fait que ça marche plus
c'est parce que c est un moment donné il
ya une pléiade de problèmes
bureaucratiques qui peuvent être
aplanies et qui continuent d'être dans
le système alors c'est pour ça que ça le
robinet ouvert hier 7
cette photo de ce petit garçon de 3 ans
alain cordier a ému toute la planète
leur lancée et j'ouvre une petite
parenthèse
les gens qui disent les aux médias vous
devriez pas parce que si l'esprit humain
est l'intrus main et fait ainsi que on a
souvent besoin que ça passe par les
motifs avant de rationaliser que je vous
dise qu'à vingt trente quarante mille
personnes qui sont sur la méditerranée
est un concept voir un enfant de 3 à
mourir et en passant il y en a sept cent
vingt mille de cet âge là dans cette
région là réfugiés migrants
bref voilà pourquoi on a diffusé hier
qu'on en reparle aujourd'hui donc cette
photo m'a ému la planète imaginée en
plein milieu de la nuit le minet
s'apprend qui voulaient venir au canada
cette famille que cette famille love
love n'est que le frère de celui qui
était pleurer aujourd'hui parce que père
de six enfants voulaient venir et que
tout ce monde aurait pu avoir une aide à
vancouver dont on aurait pu s'installer
la maison est assez grande plusieurs
chambres pour les recevoir parce que ça
fait aussi au delà du coc très
particulier c'est que ça braque les
projecteurs sur le bilan du gouvernement
conservateur en matière de gestion des
réfugiés
lorsqu'on se rencontrent c'est qu'entre
2006 et 2014 on a une baisse de 28 % du
nombre de réfugiés qu'on accueille ici
au canada
on en accueille moins qu'avant et des
raisons pour ça mais on peut donc poser
des questions au gouvernement sortant
qui va être élu pour kunkel - d'oeil aux
réfugiés qu'on en avait avant de couper
par exemple les soins médicaux non
urgents ou réfugiés qui viennent ici
maintenant c'est les provinces quelle
somme soit entre avons décidé de ne plus
assumer ces frais médicaux là il ya une
gestion du gouvernement qui est
difficile antenna avec sont en ce moment
en parler davantage à temps mais patrice
savoie où le lot
d'abord cette crise des réfugiés c'est
une crise qui prend des proportions
comme on les a pas vus depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale
cc c'est pas un petit phénomène quand la
photo de cet enfant est apparue ça
faisait quand même plusieurs jours qu'on
voyait toutes sortes d'autres choses
ça n'a pas empêché le ministre hier
après-midi d'aller chez vos collègues
pour dire c'est la faute aux médias
si la série fasse quelques pas mieux et
ça n'a pas empêché le gouvernement
jusqu'à ce qu'ils découvrent qu'ils
avaient mené
si on canadienne qui allait peut-être le
mettre dans l'embarras le gouvernement
avait prévu aujourd'hui comme activité
de campagne une conférence de presse
2009 john kani qui allait expliquer
comment on allait resserrer les critères
d'immigration alors cette crise
humanitaire
le gouvernement de toute évidence dans
sa façon d'agir jusqu'à ce que ça touche
directement que celui sorte de figure se
sentait absolument pas concerné par ça
et même aujourd'hui monsieur harper qui
dit il faut faire beaucoup mais qui se
sert de cette histoire posés ça prouve
que j'ai raison d'être en guerre contre
l' état islamique et que les autres
entend s'essayer à une question de régis
le quai absolument des classes est
d'ailleurs chantage vous je prends le
relais je vais vous faire écouter
l'extrait de monsieur harper aujourd'hui
cet après midi 13h45
il est incompréhensible moment entrevoir
une vraie image et conclure et on peut
conclure qu'on devait faire plus de
quelque chose et - moins de résistance
l'état de la mecque
- 2 dead pour des personnes qui devaient
la invariablement on doit faire plus
en attendant train de faire plus alors
monsieur qui évidemment souligner le
fait que monsieur trudeau et monsieur
mulcair veulent se retirer de la
coalition qui bombardé des positions de
détenus par le i à eddy très bien mais
moi je fais ça réactions les enduits
dans les canadiens vous d'avoir le
premier ministre du canada et en vue le
chef du parti conservateur
d'abord juste sur le fond avait ce jeu
chose sur la forme avec des candidats
conservateurs autour de lui les
militants conservateurs qui
applaudissait l'ailé des réponses de
monsieur un peu il y avait juste à faire
ça dans une salle avec pas de militants
conservateurs
aujourd'hui c'est la journée du 1er
c'était pas aux journées du chef de
parti ça c'est la première des choses
la deuxième c'est qu'on s'attendait à ce
qu'ils disent mais il ya quelque chose
qui marche pas dans notre système
j'ai donné instruction pour l'examen de
revoir le renard je sais pas mais dire
on a fait plus que tout le monde a peur
à berck à peter et dire après ça de
toute façon ma guerre à la fois c'est la
façon de régler ça je pense que beaucoup
de 15 et comme dit choqué par ça allait
mais en fait le problème syrienne date
potes de l'entrée en scène du groupe
armé islamique en date de la guerre
j'ai commencé avec bachar el-assad qui
d'ailleurs encore à ce jour la plus
grande menace pour les civils syriens
bien davantage que les groupes armés
islamistes tous les experts sur le
terrain vont dire donc si ça date depuis
2000 ont ce problème là comment ça se
fait que seulement lorsqu'on a commencé
à bombarder le groupe à terme islamique
on s'est mis à faire quelque chose
les gens qui pour accord avec la réalité
là c'est vrai toutefois que le canada
donne beaucoup d'argent donne parmi les
plus inconditionnels
on ne reçoit pas beaucoup de réfugiés on
donne beaucoup d'argent c'est la
décision que le gouvernement a pris dans
les dernières années
chantal sur cette lutte parce que si tu
prends une fracture entre les libéraux
et les néo démocrates et les
conservateurs cette lutte contre l'état
islamique n'était pas la bonne journée
pour en parler mais déjà la frime et le
débat épaules le débat et la fracture
est dans le rôle du canada dans le monde
et la vision quant à monsieur à peu par
rapport à celle des partis d'opposition
et aujourd'hui franchement je pense que
le gouvernement aurait aidé son message
si la place de dire qu'on va faire plus
et à berd'huis on peut faire mieux et
moi je suis mal à l'aise à l'idée que le
ministre suspendu sa campagne électorale
pour aller donner une entrevue pour un
gros dire c'est pas de ma faute
dans ce cas aussi plutôt que pour venir
annoncer aux canadiens voici ce qu'on va
faire de mieux monsieur trudeau et c'est
la réaction pour concurrents semblent
plutôt aujourd'hui je dois vous dire que
les images d'aujourd'hui d'un jeune
garçon en train d'être ramassés sur une
plage sont chauds qui vont rester avec
tout le monde pour longtemps
comme père comme grand père je trouve ça
un soutenable de voir ce qu'on est en
train de voir là alors oui il faut faire
plus je trouve ça très commode pour un
politicien comme monsieur à l'exode de
toutacoup découvrir en pleine campagne
électorale le besoin d'être con
passionnés
pour moi c'est une faille est qu'on a
souligné depuis longtemps et de monsieur
alexander et de monsieur kani et ultime
ans de monsieur harper de n'avoir pas
agi comme les canadiens s'attendent à ce
que le gouvernement agisse
c'est une drôle de question et je vous
pose pas ces questions leur d'habitude
mais est ce que vous croyez pas ce que
vous n'êtes pas des firmes de sondage ce
que vous croyez que les canadiens
effectivement dans leur grande majorité
aimeraient que leurs gouvernements peu
importe la couleur en fasse plus dans un
dossier comme celui aujourd'hui
certainement est la raison pour laquelle
les conservateurs ont changé leur
programme de campagne qui l'ont amené
monsieur cannes et du chemin qu'ils ont
sortis de la circulation un peu monsieur
alexander c'est parce qu'ils ont senti
qu'ils avaient souvent là est ce qu'ils
ont réussi à répondre à cet élan là
parce qu'ils sont les seuls qui
pouvaient répondre ce gouvernement qui
peut agir c'est pas les partis
d'opposition en campagne on verra je
veux pour clarifier les choses
on a fait faire un tableau et j'en suis
membre c'est quoi les différences entre
les différents à grands partis sur un
peu avait dit dont dix mille réfugiés
syriens et irakiens
de plus il a ajouté un d'e-mails en
début de campagne donc c'est pour ça que
ça fait 23 mai au total il a ajouté 13
milles en fait ce mail car il dit
maintenant là il dit ce matin dix mille
réfugiés immédiatement pour renouveler
pas comment les faits que pour le kosovo
pour les boat people pour un dans
d'autres cas et monsieur trudeau il dit
vingt-cinq mille réfugiés le plus tôt
possible donc séduit 3 ans demain ce
n'est pas le moment de donner tous les
détails mais voilà vous avez l'éventail
des propositions dans cette campagne
électorale concernant ce sujet en
conclusion le ca dépasse la bataille
électorale 1 6 et 1 c c'est un moment où
peut-être qu'on aurait dû mettre mettre
en parenthèse la campagne est comme
jésus michel que le premier ministre
sorte de sa caravane
ouais parce qu'il est premier ministre
jusqu'aux élections il est évidemment le
chef conservateur en campagne mais les
des moments où autant de s'élever
généralement le je pense que ça faisait
partie de ces moments là pour répondre à
la première question
est ce que les canadiens vont avoir ça
en tête au moment d'aller voter vous
savez que les affaires étrangères est
rarement une préoccupation fondamentale
chez les canadiens lors des élections
par contre la réputation du canada dans
le monde sont généralement les canadiens
tiennent et si on a l'impression que la
réputation du canada qui du canada qui
accueillait des réfugiés est un terre
d'accueil s'est disloqué dans les
dernières années claude est pointé du
doigt directement avec un drame que les
gens peuvent associer à nous pas certain
que les canadiens prix c'est beaucoup
conclusion chez duceppe a eu un bon
réflexe aujourd'hui en alsace et il faut
faire une très partisane pas de
partisanerie là dessus c'est un peu ce
que monsieur walker a dit mathieu raison
monsieur trudeau et par l'élan
vieillesse et d'attaquer le gouvernement
je préfère que ça va l'aider de l'avoir
fait mais c'est un fait que ces genres
de choses qui exige qu'on s'élève au
dessus de la partisanerie aujourd'hui
parce que franchement le drame écumait
d'abord et tout le monde qu il serait
réunion d'urgence en europe dimanche
pour avoir parlé c'est un et chantal
vous à bien faire le souvenez c'est
depuis la deuxième guerre mondiale
l'europe et la planète donc nous avons
été aux prises avec des vagues comme ça
de réfugiés qu'on appelait des migrants
parce que toutes sortes de catégories
mais ce dont on parle c'est beaucoup des
réfugiés et cela merci beaucoup au
revoir ses avoirs